Yeah,
yeah.
Kept trying to get this interview.
So what could the second blank dollars
to,
how many houses can you you use private?
How many jumps can you own?
So give the,
give the rest of it away.
But if I were giving money away,
I would probably give it mostly to
direct service providers as people
actually,
or they're actually doing research say
for giving me cancer research for AIDS
research.
The actual researchers and the people
actually providing on the ground
services to peel because there's plenty
of think tanks.
There's plenty of things that get a lot
of money to turn a lot of position
papers and some of them are usable
position papers.
Board tend to be underfunded by private
donors today or people give him the
services on the ground.
Little things that aren't sexy.
Soup Kitchens,
food closets,
things like that.
Those are desperately under funded by
private donors or give to the big issues
that get something named after yourself
and so on.
I think if money mainly to causes like
that and something else,
I think I might give away money to
establish writing programs,
um,
writing programs,
especially in the inner city,
but elsewhere as well in rural areas,
places where a lot of times,
or it can certainly go to school,
they don't get the individual
encouragement to think about the
possible you may have the talent to be a
writer.
Let's try it out and,
and see you saying that people tend to
ride a lot.
10 of people think a lot and we need
more.
People will think a lot and I'd like to
encourage that.